[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
nach dieser woche begrüße ich sie aus
meinem wohnzimmer wer kann soll daheim
bleiben und von hier aus spreche ich
nachher gleich mit dem schweizer
schriftsteller lukas bärfuss per skype
der computer ist das fenster zur welt
geworden unsere kinder lösen hier ihre
hausaufgaben
unsere jüngste bekommt ihre hafen stunde
inzwischen virtuell und auch wir großen
können uns mit diesem teil ganz viel
kultur nach hause holen konkrete tipps
dazu nachher später in der sendung
zuerst einmal willkommen auf dem
kulturplatz
[Musik]
aber zuerst schauen wir auch die prekäre
lage in der kulturbranche fast alle
kreativschaffenden befinden sich aktuell
in einer existenziell bedrohlichen
situation nun hat das bundesamt für
kultur soforthilfe gesprochen 280
millionen franken um die korona krise
irgendwie zu überstehen die frage ist
nur wie werden diese gelder jetzt fair
aufgeteilt die nächste herausforderung
am abend spontan ins kino
die lieblings musikerin live sehen der
geplante theater abend alles nicht mehr
möglich letzte woche hatten wir uns in
der stillgelegten kulturszene rom
die vielfalt ist damit sogar geld aus
dem riskanten errichtet wo man sich dann
quasi album zu schreiben
die hilferufe wurden erhört in einem
schnellverfahren hat der bundesrat ein
zusätzliches maßnahmenpaket für die
kultur gesprochen
280 millionen für soforthilfe und
ausfall entschädigungen
ich bin zufrieden mit dem resultat ich
bin auch sehr froh dass der bundesrat
die kultur auch im generellen
wirtschaftlichen maßnahmenpaket
involviert ragt das war ein erster
großer schritt aber wir haben sofort
gemerkt wir brauchen noch zusätzliche
maßnahmen weil der kultursektor einen
besonderen zweig eigentlich auch in der
wirtschaftstätigkeit in unserem land ist
die kultur wurde also zusätzlich
berücksichtigt doch wie einigt man sich
auf eine summe von 280 millionen
wie definiert man wer auf faire art wie
viel bekommt das ist ja wunderbar
roboter saga vor extremer
solidarisierung frauen deutlich um
betroffen das bundesamt für kultur um
mehr ein sehr schöner zwei metern höhe
gemacht mit verbands vertreterinnen und
vertreter
und kulturschaffende wo man versucht
haben problemlage sammler gehören in
welcher dimension und wenn eine
typologie probleme entstehen
für diesen einsatz bedanken sich die
kulturverbände umgeht auch rosmarie
quadranti die sich für die
interessenverbände der schweizer
kulturinstitutionen einsetzt er weiß
jetzt ruhig finanzielle hilfe
ich muss meine institutionen zu machen
aber jetzt muss das quasi das muss ich
machen
unter buch zeiss merkblatt wer wandert
sich wohl und dann haben wir klarheit
klar wirtschaft ruhe kraft beruhigt und
die krise münze für ruhe sorgen
und ich glaube schon zwei wichtige
aufgabe das bundesamt für kultur
zusammen mit pro helvetia zweck muss
leisten
der ruf nach einer zentralen
informationsplattform ist verständlich
genauso wie die komplexität einer
solchen koordination
es sind verschiedene informationsquellen
plant sowohl das bundesamt für kultur
ist auf hochtouren informationen ford
bereitet mir sieht es privat sie haben
schon oft der website gewisse
informationen wo laufend aktualisiert
werden wiederum mit kanten und
stiftungen im gespräch dass die
information koordiniert wird nannte ihre
17 grad informationen office laden
ziel wäre jemand leitfaden wo so einfach
wie möglich die betroffenen tore führt
durch die verschiedenen instrumente die
aktuelle lage ist vor allem für
selbstständig erwerbende
kulturschaffende prekär wie kann ein
schauspieler die miete bezahlen wenn
kein engagement mehr da ist wie soll
eine autorin für ihre kinder sorgen wenn
die lesetour wegfällt
und was macht eine künstlerin wenn sie
ihre bilder nicht mehr ausstellen kann
genau für diese einzelpersonen hat der
bund nun eine zentrale anlaufstelle
definiert swiss bild uci an
die gelder stammen von den gesprochenen
280 millionen
dank ist das ganze projekt für manche wo
kulturbereichs kunststoffen die sind im
eine weitere singers muss fehlt bis
jetzt dank das muss ich ja vorstellen
aber der klassische kunstschaffende sind
daher zum gespräch licht und tontechnik
damit also alles und vermutlich so oder
so hintergrund bereiche der kultur das
im ritz nun genau definieren wer ganz
genau das dynamisch und es sind aber
ganz wichtig ist es sind nur individuell
für kulturinstitutionen stehen die
kantonalen stellen bereit auch sie
bedienen sich an den 280 millionen
die soforthilfe von swiss kultur steht
im zeichen der fairness damit auch
kulturschaffende die kein erspartes
haben über die runden kommen
das gaben die effektive nothilfe für
härtefälle das heißt mehr leistet jetzt
steht hilflos vor helga krohn und
übergang zum sport die zange oder
gesundheitsfonds wie effektiv ja auch
die not und das formular wird anfang
nächster woche hochgeschaltet bis dahin
gibt's weiterhin die eigeninitiativen im
netz wie zum beispiel die plattform
kultur klinik auf der man kultur kaufen
oder verkaufen
kann die korona krise zeigt der gesamte
kultursektor ist kreativ und reagiert
schnell und vielleicht kann diese
schwierige zeit auch blinde flecken
sichtbar machen
das ist eine wohn ich bisher gesprochen
klar dass die gesamte kulturlandschaft
für andere düstere situation hervorgehen
wird
und wenn sie uns gelingt die ihr chance
nutzen wo jetzt offengelegt werden und
sagen was haben sie stehen könnte für
andere oder um es anders zu sagen weil
die fragilität von system spürt man
jetzt nicht durch kroner kreiert ist
sondern wo krone eine kurve legt das
prekariat die enorme abhängigkeit von
kulturschaffenden kulturinstitutionen
von funktionierendem art dass man die
kritische und sich überlegt wie man das
ganze in zukunft andere dass sich sicher
besonders ist vorname wenn man krise
klöstern
bis dahin gilt durchhalten
leichter gesagt als getan
bleibt daheim seid vernünftig so klingt
das von der landesregierung und auch im
internet kursierte der hashtag stay at
home
doch viele lassen sich immer noch nur
langsam stoppen
mitten in dieser krise übt der schweizer
schriftsteller lukas bärfuss harsche
kritik an seiner heimat und bevor ich
jetzt gleich mit ihm spreche per skype
einige gedanken zu aktuellen
ausnahmesituationen von unserer seite
die öffentlichen plätze sind leer
oder sollten es sein die läden sind
geschlossen unser gesellschaftliches
leben bis auf weiteres runtergefahren
wir schränken uns ein weil wir müssen
uns frei bewegen dürfen wir nicht mehr
wie schaffen wir es dass auf dauer
einzuhalten
sind wir einer solchen notsituation
gewachsen
wie gehen wir mit den bildern um wenn in
unserem nachbarland die leute sterben
wie gehen wir mit den zahlen um die uns
zeigen dass sich die zahl der kranken
alle paar tage verdoppelt
wie gehen wir mit der unsichtbaren
gefahr um die wir nicht fassen können
wie gehen wir mit der zeit um die uns
zuhause lang wird aber uns gleichzeitig
davon läuft
wir kennen keinen umgang dafür bisher
gab es für alles ein auffangnetz waren
wir krank konnten wir auf unser kranken
system vertrauen ging es uns schlecht
gingen wir zu freunden unsere
sozialsysteme waren intakt erleben wir
jetzt ihren zusammenbruch
was tun wenn kein netz uns mehr auf
hängt in zeiten der katastrophe
[Musik]
wir leben in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft
wir sind es gewohnt mitzubestimmen
mitzureden wir befolgen vorschriften
wenn sie vorher von der mehrheit
abgesegnet wurden
das kennen wir doch jetzt gibt es nichts
mitzureden
jetzt gibt es nur zu befolgen und zwar
zu unserem eigenen schutz als
gesellschaft aber dafür brauchen wir das
die ganze bevölkerung jetzt mit macht
was uns schützt das ist unser verhalten
freiheiten werden beschnitten
der einzelne verliert schnell an
bedeutung denn eine pandemie
interessiert sich nicht für den
einzelnen für das virus sind wir alle
gleich ein domino stein in einer
infektiösen reihe eine statistische zahl
seiner reichweite
alles was der pandemie im wege steht
dient der potenz ihrer wucht das
einzusehen fällt uns schwer wie er die
glauben alles mitbestimmen zu können
uns fällt es schwer damit umzugehen dass
unser normales handeln plötzlich anderem
schaden zufügt wir müssen es einsehen
und danach handeln
sonst werden wir wie zum finger am abzug
einer unsichtbaren waffe einer gewalt
die uns und unsere nächsten tötet es
scheint schwer zu akzeptieren dass durch
unser handeln jemand sterben könnte das
dann ein gesundheitssystem kollabiert
wir verdrängen lieber dass es uns am
ende alle treffen könnte
in der schweiz sind schon fast 10.000
infiziert und die zahlen steigen
wir wissen es wird viele tote geben und
wir müssen machtlos zusehen was macht
das mit uns wie gehen wir als
gesellschafter mit extremer krise was
ist ihr eindruck einer die dringlichkeit
vor der situation dass man wirklich
immer in eine ernsthafte krise steckt
hat sie noch viel leichter was hat das
für konzerte noch wie mein gewicht gibt
es wirklich
ich bin bringt das netzwerk aus kreisen
der führenden gelockt und sich dort mit
der anständig ist informieren die bahn
kostet die größte sorge der gesellschaft
dass politik das ist genau das fand ich
das auch braucht einen tag vor der krise
nein ich denke wir außerordentlich
verwertung von druck oder höher als
korrektiv 2008 und los geht s richtig
kritisch zuhören was wird der gräser mit
als macher die pandemie was wie gott sei
es an die vor einem jahr
was ich ihre ausblick ja es ist und
extranet besser wäre demnach stammen
das müssen uns sehr gut aus
öffentlichkeit daran eigentlich für
minis riefen sie sagen also uns
gegenwärtig so sehr und bedanken sich
brauchen bis ich begriff dieses bild zu
stellen
[Musik]
wir leben in einer ausnahmesituation und
das wird noch eine gute weile so bleiben
die kinos sind und bleiben geschlossen
und auch der schweizer filmpreis kann
momentan nicht verlieren werden nun
wurde entschieden dass dies
höchstwahrscheinlich im rahmen des
filmfestivals locarno nachgeholt werden
kann und wir können ihn jetzt schon
sagen wer ihn gewonnen hat den schweizer
filmpreis
[Musik]
diese fahrt führt ins ziel
emilia dello russo avanciert zum besten
spielfilm
das drama handelt von einem
pubertierenden jungen der auf dem land
aufwächst
beeindruckend gespielt von luc brüche
wie auch regisseur in die höhe riss sie
in ihrer video-botschaft unterstreicht
[Musik]
ich möchte eine spezielle botschaft
anlegt grüße schicken
den hauptdarsteller dieses films der auf
seinen zarten und breiten schultern
diese ganze geschichte trägt bravo und
mach weiter so in bildern flächen bei
sommerhitze schilderte wie die welt der
familie aus den fugen gerät als eine
freundin der mutter auftaucht
dafür gab es am montag gleich noch die
auszeichnung für das beste drehbuch
grund zur freude in einem schwierigen
moment
[Musik]
ich will nicht voraus denken was jetzt
passieren wird weil wir in einer zeit
leben in der man nicht voraussehen kann
es erlaubt uns aber über den zustand der
welt zu reden und ich freue mich jetzt
schon das gesamte team im august in
locarno wieder zu sehen und mit ihm den
quartz entgegenzunehmen
ich wünsche euch allen viel mut und
lasst uns dran bleiben auch der beste
dokumentarfilm stand von einer frau
fanny bräuning wurde für immer und ewig
geehrt
ein intimes porträt ihrer eltern dessen
soundtrack ebenfalls ausgezeichnet wurde
rami wahnsinnig froh über die nachricht
ich bin traurig dass mir nicht wie blade
runner 24 im ganze team vaud so es sind
sich für die arbeit an dem film die
mutter ist wegen multiple sklerose hals
abwärts gelähmt
was die eltern nicht hindert durch
europa zu reisen
zu sehen am freitag auf sf2 als free tv
premiere noch vor dem kinostart an einem
abend exklusiv für den schweizer film
eine spezial programmierung in
schwierigen zeiten freue mich sehr wenn
er vielleicht die bittsteller in der
herz und hrige zieht und auf das ist die
verkörperung des umweltaktivisten bruno
manser in borneo bringt wenn sheikha den
preis für die hauptrolle ein
die viel abverlangte ihr lebensentwurf
unseren gesetzlichen ziehen und sich oft
aus oslo und das können ihn jetzt auch
und man kann es lernen auf die ordnung
wie sich acht einzigartige das enge
verhältnis zwischen der lokalen
bevölkerung der peene an und bruno
manser halte bei den dreharbeiten nach
[Musik]
diesen preis
also durchaus dass viele bananen erkennt
dann ist es sehr schnell sehr intensiv
weil real wurde und so froh dass sie
mehr prominente und miriam stein ist die
beste darstellerin
als theaterschauspielerin in moskau
einfach micha lewinskys komödie über die
schweizer fischer verstehst du herr
heilmann wünscht sich dass die olivia in
dieser szene nackt ist als polizeibeamte
hatte ich den auftrag unser land vor
feindlichen einflüssen zu schützen
so wurde ich zum verdeckten ermittler
die überwachung verlief ohne weitere
zwischenfälle
[Musik]
es kann nicht angehen dass diese
mentalität
wir haben vor nichts gewusst und wir
haben überhaupt nichts falsch gemacht
weiter praktiziert wird
[Musik]
jetzt gerade seltsam steingart ist dass
ich das schöne preis übernommen
ich hoffe mich sein dass im sommer in
lugano blieben alex und ich bleibe auf
jeden fall gesund und mit senderos messi
firma und jetzt tauchen wir ein in die
dunkle finstere welt der krimis der
schweizer schriftsteller hans jörg
schneider legt nach kuba in der wildnis
heißt der zehnte fall des beliebten
basar kommissars in rente ja und dieser
fall diese neue geschichte ist eine
willkommene abwechslung in unseren tagen
aber hat auch noch einiges mit unserer
aktuellen situation zu tun der kann ein
feld park in basel einst ein friedhof
hier ließ der schriftsteller hans jörg
schneider gerne zeitung gönnt sich einen
kaffee nicht so die letzten tage nicht
so heute die korona krise fordert ihren
tribut
der kiosk ist geschlossen der fast 82
jährige zu hause wo er auch seinen
neuesten home koller zu papier gebracht
hat mit stift schneider erreichen wir
via festnetz schneiders waffe im kampf
gegen korona
weiter schreiben ein glücksfall für alle
fans zehn hunkeler krimis liegen nun vor
sechs davon wurden mit mathias gnädinger
in der titelrolle verfilmt
funkel leistet widerstand gegen das
establishment die angepassten gegen
gewalt und verbrechen auch in hunkeler
in der wildnis der kahlen feldpark in
basel einst ein friedhof hier liest
kommissar peter hunkeler gerne zeitung
gönnt sich einen kaffee so auch an einem
sonnigen sonntagmorgen
doch plötzlich hilferufe
da unten liegt ein toter mann dem der
schädel eingeschlagen wurde an die mauer
gelehnt
der tote heinrich schmidinger literatur
und theaterkritiker in rente
am tatort boule kugel die mordwaffe
[Musik]
der tod hat der einzug gehalten mitten
in basel als die welt mit sich einig zu
sein schien
das unvorhersehbare unheimliche bricht
sich bahn
das leben fragil zu fragil wie wir alle
seit ein paar tagen wissen
ein narr wer sich in sicherheit wähnt
die parallelen zwischen fiktion und
realität frappant allgemeine totalität
sich natürlich auch mit haben wonach
lief war
die glatte oberfläche zu durchbrechen
darin sieht schneider seine aufgabe als
literat in hochlar in der wildnis
gelingt ihm das beispielhaft sein
stilmittel der kontrast
bis zum bitteren ende lässt schneider
idylle und brachiale gewalt
aufeinanderprallen
es wird gemordet und gewildert der
mensch ein tier
obwohl hunkeler im ruhestand ist lässt
ihm vor allem der fall schmidinger keine
ruhe um schmidinger ist es übrigens
nicht schwanger martin war komponist
aber die banausen der basler musikszene
haben ihn tot gebissen
vor allem schmidinger die bestie auch
der kommissar wird verfolgt in der
wildnis in der zivilisation in träumen
wird auf schritt und tritt mit der
endlichkeit konfrontiert doch den autor
trifft diese unerwartet mit aller wucht
gegen korona 50 jahre solidarität
[Musik]
ja zum bücherlesen haben wir mehr zeit
als auch schon und sie lokale
buchhandlungen sind angewiesen auf
unsere buchbestellungen aber auch neben
dem bücherlesen ist die welt auch jetzt
noch groß genug um uns mit kultur zu
retten wenigstens die virtuelle welt
[Musik]
wichtig es ist natürlich wirklich so
dass man jetzt beengte situationen zu
klaustrophobie verursachen die situation
was ich nicht mal wird stuhlgang im
ministerrat wird wohl fühlen für partie
basler ist es in zeiten wie diesen der
ort um ihre comedy zu platzieren
das internet wird gerade noch wichtiger
auch museen wie das museum of modern art
in new york bieten online videos an
er entpuppt sich gar hollywood-star
steve martin als kenner abstrakter
malerei sehr kreativ ist hierzulande das
kunsthaus baselland jeden donnerstag
können sich interessierte persönlich
aber ansteckung sicher ein kunstwerk
erklären lassen
per telefon
[Musik]
die 44 schweizer jugendfilmtage machen
aus der not eine tugend und zeigen alle
eingereichten werke online eben srf
koproduzierten film the lonely orbit
geht es darum dass ein satelliten
techniker seine einsamkeit bewältigen
will indem er ständig sms an seine
freude schickt aktualität in zeiten von
corona er schreibt seit ein paar tagen
an corona tagebuch der schweizer
schriftsteller peter stamm teilt auf der
webseite des aga literaturhauses seine
gedanken mit der öffentlichkeit genauso
wie dorothee elmiger die dort am 21 märz
unter anderem folgendes schreibt jemand
hustet in der nähe des brots
im rahmen der aktion sfz oder bietet
unsere website treffpunkt ch / kultur
laufend neue kulturtipps darunter
ausgewählte vielen perlen fürs heimkino
und am samstag gibt es bei sf zwei und
radio sf3 eine 24 stunden live show mit
vielen prominenten kultur schaffen
alles wird gut
[Musik]
und danke an poker wird lage ist
hoffnungslos aber nicht ernst
das war es für heute aus meinem home
office ab nächster woche übrigens haben
wir hier auch eine virtuelle wege mit
künstlerinnen und künstlern die aus
ihrem alltag berichten
zu zeiten von corona in diesem sinne
bleiben sie gesund bleiben sie daheim
bis bald es bleibt zu hause
[Musik]
münster
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
fristlos